[Applaus]
[Musik]
mit wladimir putin geht es vielen ein
wenig so wie die ihrem chef
man mag dich du dich gut man traut ihm
auch nicht besonders stark
aber man braucht ihn nun mal um seine
vita bezahlen zu können
es ist schon lange her dass wir uns hier
auch diese politik mit ihm unterhalten
haben und ja ich weiß dass ihr jetzt
denkt willst du es schon wieder etwas
über erdöl erzählen mag nun diesmal
nicht heute werden wir unsere erdgas
unterhalten viele von euch mögen und öl
und erdgas seien doch sehr ähnliche
dinge
letztendlich verfügen länder mit
ölreserven in der regel auch über
gasvorkommen
aber es gibt einen entscheidenden
unterschied
die märkte für erdöl sind viel stärker
diversifiziert als die für erdgas
ein beispiel europa kauft 30 prozent
seines rohöls von russland aber wenn es
um gas geht steigt diese zahl schon auf
40 prozent in einzelnen europäischen
ländern ist diese abhängigkeit noch
weitaus höher
deutschland importiert 60 prozent seines
erdgases aus russland andere länder wie
finnland und das baltikum sind sogar
vollständig von russischen erdgas
abhängig
mit anderen worten putin könnte diesen
ländern in einer kalten winternacht das
gas abdrehen um sich so hart spielen
lassen dass ihnen game of thrones wie
eine folge von baywatch vorteil
aber passt jetzt mal einen augenblick
gut aus denn im rohstoff gas steckt mehr
als nur wärme
tatsächlich brauchen sie erdgas für
viele andere dinge denn der verbrauch
durch haushalte macht nur rund ein
drittel der gesamtmenge aus
[Musik]
hier auf dieser grafik sehen könnt geht
ein weiteres drittel und heizkraftwerke
der größte teil wird von einem breiten
spektrum von industrieunternehmen ist so
benötigt beispielsweise ein
papierhersteller extrem viel wärme
energie
das heißt einfach große hitze um diese
zu erzeugen nutzt die fabrik gas und das
gilt auch für andere branchen mit
anderen worten gas ist für alle von
großer bedeutung und das gilt natürlich
für ganz europa und jetzt ratet mal wer
der größte gasverbrauch in ganz europa
ist
richtig geraten es ist deutschland das
bevölkerungsreichste land des kontinents
und auch das land mit der größten
wirtschaft und genau das ist der
knackpunkt dieser geschichte denn
solange deutschland von russland
abhängig ist wird auch ganz europa und
russland abhängig seien und deshalb hat
donald trump auf dem nato-gipfel 2018
folgendes gesagt deutschland wird
vollständig von russland kontrolliert
weil es 60 bis 70 prozent seines gases
aus einer neuen pipeline beziehen wird
und sagt mir ob ihr denkt dass so was
angemessen ist denn ich denke dass es
das nicht ist und ich denke er ist
schlecht für die nato die frage heute
lautet also hat trump rechts schöner
deutschland kritisiert ist es wirklich
ein problem dass deutschland derartig
von russischem gas abhängig ist und was
noch wichtiger ist versucht jemand
überhaupt diese abhängigkeit irgendwie
zurückzufahren heute werden wir alle
diese fragen beantworten aber bevor wir
das tun lasst uns einen blick in die
geschichte werfen
[Musik]
unser mann in berlin
es gibt zwei möglichkeiten gar zu
transportieren die billigste ist durch
eine pipeline
das bedeutet dass wir eine riesige
leitung bauen die von der region von der
wir das gas beziehen sagen wir der jamal
halbinsel in russland bis zu dem land
das ist letztendlich kauft wie zb
deutschland fühlt das ist ziemlich
billig weil man nur das rohr bauen muss
und das war's man braucht keine
lastwagen keine schiffe und andere
transportmöglichkeiten die dauernde
verfahren da das gas durch rohre
transportiert wird kommt es auf direktem
wege zu den stärken den häusern und den
vertreten es gibt auch eine alternative
möglichkeit der transport von so
genannten flüssigerdgas oder elegy für
das englische wort liquid natural gas
wie funktioniert diese methode nun sagen
wir mal wir nehmen das gas aus katar
dann senkte seine temperaturen bis minus
160 grad celsius erreicht das ist der
punkt an dem das gas flüssig wird und
man ist in flaschen aufbewahren kann
diese flaschen können wir auf schiff
laden und sagen wir mal nach bastians
portieren
dort steht eine rückweisung anlage in
der die flüssigkeit kontrolliert wärmt
werden kann
bis sie wieder zu gast dieses gas
gelangt daraufhin in die verschiedenen
plätze und wird so zu den häusern und
fabriken transportiert was ist nun der
vorteil dieses verfahrens
naja es ermöglicht europa seinen
gasversorger leichter zu wechseln das
problem ist allerdings die variante der
verflüssigung ist 50 bis 70 prozent
teurer als der transport über pipelines
und aus diesem grund kaufen die
europäischen länder ihr gas von den
nächstgelegenen produzenten die
parkplätze der größte lieferant für
spanien ist beispielsweise algerien die
nördlichen länder jedoch beziehen ihr
gast alle entweder aus norwegen oder
seinem noch größeren teil aus russland
wie bereits erwähnt stammt mehr als die
hälfte des in deutschland verbrauchten
gases von unternehmen wie ausläuft oder
lukoil und was ist mit den ländern die
zwischen deutschland und russland
sie stecken noch tiefer in der
abhängigkeit seht euch nur mal diese
karte an
wenn ihr aufmerksam seid seht ihr dass
75 prozent des polnischen gasbedarfs aus
russischen quellen stammt in anderen
ländern wie finnland und rumänien steigt
die abhängigkeit auf 100 prozent
mit anderen worten die hälfte europas
braucht russland um zu überleben und das
ist kein geheimnis die europäische
kommission weist das la die mir tut ihn
weiß davon und sogar er weiß ist germany
become totally dependent deutschland
wird völlig abhängig sein von der
russischen energie wenn es nicht sofort
den kurs ändern
hier in der westlichen hemisphäre setzen
wir uns dafür ein unsere unabhängigkeit
vor dem eindringen expansionistische
ausländischer mächte zu beschützen
aber lasst uns dieses video hier verein
momentan halten
genau hier wo wir die deutsche
delegation sehen können die über trump
lacht er sagte gerade das deutschland
gänzlich von der russischen energie
abhängig sein wird
das bedeutet wenn deutschland vorher
schon abhängig war
wird diese abhängigkeit nun noch größer
wovon redet er da genau
nun lasst uns das video mal zurückspulen
[Gelächter]
erinnert ihr euch an gerhard schröder
den ehemaligen deutschen kanzler den
vorgänger von angela merkel
er hat nach wie vor einen massiven
einfluss auf die deutsche und auch auf
die europäische politik und was macht er
jetzt nur er braucht es hier
ehemalige generalsekretär der nato
rasmussen deutschland tappt in putins
falle nord stream 2 im wesentlichen
handelt es nicht bei nordstream zwei um
eine brandneue pipeline die in der
ostsee verläuft und deutschland mit
russland direkt verbindet mit dieser
neuen pipeline könnte deutschland seine
importe von russischem gas
der hauptgesellschafter dieses projekt
ist das vom russischen staat
kontrollierte erdgasförderunternehmen
gazprom und der vorsitzende des
verwaltungsrats
dieses projekt ist natürlich gerhard
schröder
und als ob das noch nicht genug wäre ist
der ehemalige deutsche kanzler auch noch
der aufsichtsratsvorsitzende von cnet
einer russischen ölgesellschaft
[Musik]
deshalb wurde schröder in den letzten
zehn jahren zu putins man in europa
tatsächlich hat er russland in allen
möglichen belangen verteidigt von den
cyber angriffen gegen die regierung bis
zur krippe invasion mit anderen worten
in deutschland ist weit davon entfernt
seine abhängigkeit von russland zu
verringern und geht ganz im gegenteil in
die genau entgegengesetzte richtung also
worüber lachen die durchschnittlich
ehrlich gesagt ich habe keine ahnung
[Musik]
john street 2 trump verhängt sanktionen
gegen russische gaspipeline präsident
donald trump hat ein gesetz
unterzeichnet das sanktionen gegen jede
firma vor sich die dem staatlichen
russischen gasunternehmen gazprom bei
der fertigstellung an der pipeline in
die europäische union hilft die russen
geben sich jedoch nicht geschlagen sie
wollen die pipeline mit ihrem eigenen
spezialschiff fertigstellen
[Musik]
russische spezialschiff vor rügen lässt
konflikt um nord stream 2 wieder
hochkochen die arbeiten waren ende 2009
10 zum erliegen gekommen nachdem der
us-kongress unter führung von
us-präsident sonst aktionen gegen firmen
und gm-manager verhängt hatte die
schiffe zum bau der pipeline zur
verfügung gestellt hatten daraufhin
hatte der in der schweiz ansässige
offshore dienstleister aussiehst sein
schiff pioneering spirit von dem projekt
abgezogen
[Musik]
doch nun hat das verlegeschiff
akademiker schewski vor wenigen tagen im
hafen sassnitz mukran auf gründen rund
300 kilometer nördlich von berlin
angelegt wenn gazprom die akademiker ski
eines um 19 2 fertig zu bauen muss und
wird der us-präsident sanktionen gegen
das land verhängen die manager würden
mit einem einreiseverbot in den usa
belegt und ihre sämtlichen
vermögenswerte werden eingefroren werden
und das ist erst der anfang erklärte us
senator ted cruz von den republikanern
offiziell fürchten die usa dass mit der
fertigstellung von nord stream die
abhängigkeit europas von russischem gas
weiter steigt allerdings verbinden die
usa auch handfeste wirtschaftliche
interessen mit den sanktionen geht es
tramp doch auch um bessere exportchancen
für die eigene gasindustrie
diese neuen sanktionen könnten natürlich
auch die europäischen investoren omv
wintershall der ende juni per und shell
treffen die am projekt beteiligt
[Musik]
die kompromisslose härte der amerikaner
hat alle überrascht und die deutsche
wirtschaft fängt an sich ernsthafte
sorgen zu machen denn ohne weiteres
erdgas lassen sich die ziele welche die
deutsche regierung im rahmen der
energiewende beschlossen hat nicht
verwirklichen denn nach der abschaltung
der kern und kohlekraftwerke lassen sich
bezahlbare strompreise und eine
energieintensive industrie nur mit hilfe
von gas kraftwerk gehalten aber nicht
nur die usa wollen noch zwei steine in
den weg legen sondern auch viele
europäische länder sie boxten die
sogenannte eu gas richtlinie durch diese
schreibt vor dass der betreiber der
pipeline nicht zugleich auch der
gaslieferant sein darf außerdem müssen
dritte zugang zur pipeline bekommen
besetzt die deutsche bundesnetzagentur
musste sich dem beugen
sie gewährt zwar der alten ostring
pipeline eine ausnahme von der
eu-richtlinie nicht jedoch der neuen ost
ring 2 in der eu hat es sich für diese
richtlinie vor allem polen eingesetzt da
man dort den gas expressionismus
russlands äußerst kritisch
gegenübersteht
dort trinkt polen fordert schnelle
fortschritte bei eu gas richtlinie der
eu staaten unterstützen polens
forderungen die arbeiten an ergänzungen
der eu um gas richtlinie müssten
beschleunigt werden mit seinem aufruf
lichten warschau sich vor allem gegen
den bau der pipeline nord stream 2
widerstand kommt von allen von
deutschland wo die geplante pipeline
enden würde
[Musik]
aber okay ich weiß was ihr jetzt denkt
warum ist es ein problem so sehr von
russland abhängig zu sein
[Musik]
ist es vielleicht die tatsache dass
putin eine autoritäre herrscher ist im
ernst kommt schon wenn das ein problem
wäre könnten wir von kommen gas kaufen
auf der lieferanten liste stehen was an
algerien katar und natürlich sind das
alles kerngesunder demokratien die von
barmherzigen schwestern regiert werden
selbstverständlich kümmert sich keiner
um demokratie und menschenrechte wenn es
darum geht sein eigenes haus zu heizen
die abhängigkeit von russland ist aber
aus einem anderen grund ein großes
problem ihr werdet gleich verstehen
worum es geht
[Musik]
die horex im jahr 2006 wollte gass krump
durchsetzen dass die ukrainer sechsmal
mehr für gas bezahlen sollen als bisher
das war zu 100 prozent ein politischer
schachzug jahrzehnte lang hatten
russland und dem kleinen ein wirklich
gutes ja brüderliches verhältnis
doch dann begann die orange revolution
als viktor juschtschenko an die macht
kam mit seiner anti russischen und
pro-europäischen rhetorik da sagte der
kreml
ich verstehe ukraine du willst hast du
noch mit seinen coolen europäischen
kunden abhängen oder das gut dann hole
jetzt erstmal seinen geldbeutel raus
denn das wird verdammt gefährlich denkt
mal darüber nach
der bau einer brandneuen pipeline in
einem anderen partner land dauert jahre
die ukraine könnte also nicht einfach
über nacht neue lieferanten finden wenn
du die wollte könnte er die preise nach
belieben in die höhe treiben
und wenn die ukraine nicht bezahlen will
macht russland das rohr einfach zu
drei tage lang mitten in einer
kältewelle konnten die krainer zu hause
nicht mehr heizen und nach äußerst
angespannten verhandlungen stimmte die
ukraine zu das doppelte für das gas zu
zahlen
[Musik]
im gegenzug erhöhten sie die
transitkosten für russisches gas das
über die ukraine in andere europäische
länder nicht
dabei treten jedoch alles erst an im
jahr 2009 gab es genau das gleiche
problem nur in einer ganz anderen
dimension
russland verlangt von der ukraine noch
mehr geld für sein gas hier und moskau
begannen daraufhin sich gegenseitig zu
bereinigen und in diesem fall war es
nicht nur die ukraine die tagelang ohne
gas auskommen musste auf das übrige
europa was dazu gehört ein politischer
publik italien polen und natürlich auch
deutschland ja meine lieben zuschauer
das meiste russische gas kommt über die
ukraine
wenn also die ukraine kein gas mehr
haben stehen die chancen gut dass auch
andere europäische ihren werden wieder
endete die geschichte damit dass die
ukraine mehr für ihr gas zahlen musste
im gegenzug aber höhere transitgebühren
verlangt nicht ist doch trotz putins
lied ist genau wie in game of thrones
ein lied von eis und feuer
nachdem in den jahren 2006 und 2009
zunächst die europäer schon tiefgekühlt
wurden war 2010 das jahr des feuers und
das feuer wurde in der ukrainischen
provinz namen scream entfacht wir wissen
wir setzten die großen die krim und was
hat die europäische union an offen getan
nun sie ging zu putin und sagte proteine
unartige junge wir werden dich bestrafen
und zwar wirst du zwanzig mal
aufschreiben ich werde nicht in andere
länder eindringen und das war's jetzt
bereitet die ukraine europa mehr
kopfschmerzen als alles andere
aber dieses thema werden wir im nächsten
video dieser serie waren denn ja es wird
eine ganze serie über russisches gas
geben wenn ihr nicht verpassen wollt ist
ihr was zu tun ist abonnieren und aufs
knöpfchen klicken jetzt hat europa also
zwei möglichkeiten entweder putin und
schröder r weiter neue platte lenz
beruhen lassen und die ukraine zu
umgehen das ist die erste option die
zweite von der eu bevorzugte option ist
einfach weitere neue gaslieferanten
[Musik]
diversifikation versuche der schnellste
weg zur diversifikation der
gasversorgung ist wie ihr bestimmt schon
erraten habe der kauf von flüssigerdgas
lng
das ist natürlich teuer aber die länder
müssen nicht erst warten nun brandl
pence zu bauen wo also liegt ihr das
problem denn die schiffe sind bereits
durch die asiatischen absatzmärkte
vollkommen ausgebucht
[Musik]
im grunde genommen ist der pazifik voll
von diesen schiffen die von australien
und malaysia nach japan china und korea
fahren müssen die nicht wissen dass in
asien die gaspreise noch weitaus höher
sind als überall sonst auf der welt da
kann man der eu schon mal viel glück
wünschen amerika oder kanada von uns
überzeugen ausgerechnet ihnen ihr gas zu
verkaufen sind damit stattdessen in
asien einen reibach machen können
deshalb ist der bau neuer pipelines die
realistische optionen die frage ist nur
so
[Musik]
auf der einen seite haben wir norwegen
aber europa kauft bereits das gesamte
von norwegen produzierte gas im süden
wird spanien die mit karts bauen eine
pipeline die algerien mit nordeuropa
verbinden soll aber frankreich ist nicht
gerade begeistert von dieser idee als
selbst das gesamte netz aufbauen müsste
um das gas dann andere länder zu
verkaufen und ihr wisst ja wieder so
manchmal ist es echt krass viel arbeit
travolta war je vielleicht morgen ich
morgen schon verplant
nächste woche die bisher ernsthafteste
alternative ist die sogenannte trans
adria pipeline oder tcp die bis 2020
fertiggestellt sein soll
diese leitung führt von aserbaidschan
über die türkei bis nach italien aber
einen moment denn das reicht vorne und
hinten nicht diese pipeline hat eine
maximale kapazität von 20 milliarden
kubikmetern
und das ist noch nicht mal die hälfte
der kapazität der nordstream zwei die
deutschland und russland verbinden soll
aber das ist nicht das einzige problem
denn wenn es um gas geht wird putins
einem sehr eifersüchtigen freund wenn du
dachtest er würde so viel gas
promiskuität einfach nehmen dann liegst
du ganz falsch
gazprom gibt bekannt der gas-transit
über die ukraine nach europa sinkt auf
10 bis 15 milliarden kubikmeter pro jahr
[Musik]
diesen schachzug schlägt putin zwei
fliegen mit einer klappe erstens europa
ihm zu folgen und außerdem umgeht er die
pokale
aber das ist noch nicht alles denn im
süden drängt putin auf den bau brandneue
rohre und liebe zuschauer wenn ihr
dachtet dass gerhard schröder der
einzige freund von wladimir putin europa
ist dann liegt hier ganz weiter neben
ungarn verlangt die verlängerung der
russischen turkish stream pipeline bis
nach europa
es gibt noch zwei themen die wir hier
nicht behandelt haben zum einen müssen
wir über die ukraine sprechen kann pro
tier sie vollkommen umgehen außerdem
sollten da auch über aserbaidschan
sprechen eine weitere diktatur die
europas neuer bester freund zu werden
scheint wenn ihr diese stories also
nicht verpassen wollt meldet euch an und
klickt auf den abo button
in der zwischenzeit hier eine frage für
euch glaubt er dass deutschland seine
abhängigkeit von russland verringern
kann
oder glaubt ihr dass putin der nacht
könig werden wird mit genug macht um
alle europäer in weiße wanderer zu
verwandeln
bitte hinterlasst eure antwort im
kommentarfeld unten
wenn euch dieses video gefallen hat gebt
uns einen daumen hoch und wie immer bis
zum nächsten mal
[Musik]